we thought we'd kick it up a notch by
asking you some flaming hot spicy
questions
okay we're gonna start out mild but then
as the questions keep getting hotter and
spicier i think some
flames are gonna come up this is the
first time we've done this i'm really
excited
okay okay the heat is on here we go
all right patricia what's your go-to
song in the shower
okay well i actually do the entire
musical score
from sweeney todd i like to sing about
serial killers in the shower
i likey okay
um have you ever eaten something off the
floor that was like well past that five
second rule
um drew i just moved and i ate a skittle
that probably was in the couch for
seven years
[Laughter]
okay name a celebrity you might secretly
stalk on social media
i don't even know if it's a secret i
don't know if he knows but it it's not
actually james van der beek it's his
five glorious children i stalk his
children
they're the most beautiful kids i've
ever seen and i can't stop looking at
them
you know it's the baby i love it have
you ever peed in a pool
uh the pool the ocean and occasionally
the shower
haven't we all right i mean seriously
have you um if you could erase a project
from your imdb
what would it be if meryl streep takes
matlock
off of her resume i'll take matlock off
of my resume
that's what they call equal opportunity
and fair game
um we all have matlock on our resume by
the way
i was trying to think of um one i would
do it was a long
there's like serious five-year chunks of
some serious
bcd level stuff i've got going on in
there
okay um tell us something that uh you've
done that might be illegal
okay i'm from ohio in the 70s
who was not smoking crappy pot that
somebody grew in their basement under a
like
okay read us the last spicy text you
sent to your husband
the the the spiciest recent one was
my husband texting me saying where do
you keep the oven mitts
and i'm like honey their second drawer
down to the left of the stove
i love this so much i do i do i do
okay 30 some years of marriage so yeah
i just it's so cute and delicious i love
it so much and
and just so real and and wonderful and i
that to me is spicy
okay what is your husband's favorite
part of your body
my brain
yeah baby okay
and now our final burning question which
of your tv husbands is a better kisser
ray romano or neil flynn
i would say let me just put it this way
because rey is
also married for a very long time i'll
give it to ray
perry safe
loving um and so
wholesome and uh you and your husband
better work
like work on those oven mitts later and
get them
out and have some fun with them and
thank you for doing our spicy
questionnaire
you're the very first person to ever do
it i am so honored that i it's the
premier spice i hope you get someone who
has a little more interesting life for
the next one
it could never be and it will always be
known as the patricia and thank you so
much
thank you for joining us today and i had
the best time with you thank you
[Music]
patricia